more women are getting into the trades
and finding it to be a very productive
career path when such female started a
non-profit to encourage young girls to
do it too our local trade school is also
seeing more women enroll
if you like math and you love science
this is the job for you judalin Cassidy
is the founder of the non-profit tools
and Tiaras she works with girls aged 6
to 14. teaching them jobs don't have
genders we expose them to careers in the
construction industry and male-dominated
careers like Plumbing Aviation
um sheet metal electrical
welding tiles judalin didn't have the
financial means to attend universities
so the trades was the next best thing
she became a plumber and 25 years later
still loves it in Las Vegas recently for
a convention and launching her kids
coloring book my mom is a plumbing
superhero I want kids to see that
plumbers
um with the help of um plumbers protect
the health of the nation and we improve
people's lives every single day with
plumbing and we do much more than
install toilets and on Club bowls we're
seeing more women who
we're coming into these trades uh
because they see other women being
successful CEO Ryan Woodward of National
Technical Institute has seen enrollment
at its many Southern Nevada locations
explode since the pandemic curriculum
that is contractor built contractors
approve what is taught with it an uptick
of women mastering the HVAC plumbing and
electrical trades they get hired right
on the spot because the contractors
understand when they're good they're
very very good judalin says this career
has given her the ability to succeed in
life debt free and give back to her
community I am an immigrant and I grew
up really poor and I came to this
country and I love this country and
um it afforded me the ability to have a
house to have a 401K plan
judalin's daughter followed in her
footsteps of the trade she's a sheep
metal worker and while judalin's camp
and workshops through tools and Tiaras
are offered to girls in New York where
she lives she says anyone can start a
chapter in their hometown